bonjour et merci d'être avec ton direct
sur rt france à leur première question
concernant la guadeloupe pourquoi tant
que l'île soit dans une situation si
délicate pour que le gouvernement
remette le débat sur la table
oui alors c'est vrai que on peut
s'étonner finalement du temps que
l'exécutif a mis pour répondre à un
certain nombre de problèmes que cette
crise sanitaire n'a fait que révéler ou
exacerber parce que derrière le refus
finalement de la vaccination d'une
partie de la population en guadeloupe et
en martinique au demeurant également de
la vaccination il ay ay plie de défiance
on peut les antilles et la maire de la
métropole qui est en ciel qui est liée
notamment à des disparités des
disparités sociales économiques je
rappelle que plus d'un tiers
des jeunes sont au chômage oualalou
parce que on est largement au dessus du
seuil des 2
parties la catégorie grande partie de la
population que par ailleurs à certaines
lettres ont cruellement défaut notamment
par la frontière sud il ya en effet deux
des sciences qui est très forte et
pourquoi avoir repris et mis autant de
temps c'est qu'en fait que l'exécutif a
d'abord privilégier le rétablissement de
l'ordre public après les tic et les
multiples nuit d'émeutes on a connu en
guadeloupe alors c'était prévisible 1,7
déclarations de sébastien cornu a donné
des idées à d'autres 1 dont la corse on
a vu tout à l'heure des indépendantistes
corses qui réclament plus d'autonomie
c'est un vieux très vieux débat pensez
vous réellement que ce soit de nouveau à
l'ordre du jour
ce qui concerne l'accord d'abord il faut
rappeler que ce sont d'abord des
autonomistes qui source aujourd'hui à
pouvoir encore c'est qu'ils sont
majoritaires l'autonomie n'est pas
l'indépendance il faut être clair la
revendication d'autonomie qui est porté
notamment par ses parlementaires dont on
a dont vous avez relaté les propos
ne constitue pas une demande
d'indépendance en ce qui concerne ses
vacances qui dansa de la corse il ya une
situation qui est très différente de
celle de la guadeloupe c'est que la
différence s'est d'abord que l'exécutif
en corse il est aux mains des
autonomistes et que la majorité
aujourd'hui du côté du corps électoral
depuis lors les élections régionales
depuis depuis 2015 votre mal c'est
majoritairement pour des ondées
nationale tout à fait différent en
guadeloupe on doit tout les autonomies
eux représentent entre 9 et 10% du corps
électoral eux pas plus donc les élus
corses d'une certaine manière considère
que la stratégie démocratique qui est la
leur est une stratégie qui n'est pas
entendue par le couloir central par
paris et ils n'ont pas tout à fait tort
en la matière et que finalement il
suffirait que la violence
s'exacerbe court que
d'une certaine manière l'exécutif met
sur la table des négociations car pour
ce qui concerne la la guadeloupe la
question institutionnelle
donc c'est aussi cette différence de
traitement que les élus autonomistes ont
voulu aussi signalé à l'attention et à
l'adresse du gouvernement alors qu'hors
guadeloupe a des statuts différents il y
en a un autre également la nouvelle
calédonie on a vraiment là un statut
particulier on a un nouveau référendum
ce sera le troisième qui aura lieu le 12
décembre et plusieurs formations
indépendantistes ont reproché au
gouvernement le maintien de cette date
évoquons l'impossibilité d'organiser une
campagne équitable avec la crise
sanitaire exacte elle même au boycott
pourquoi le gouvernement français semble
rester sourd alors il y avait déjà
soulevé vous après le résultat du
premier référence du second référendum
il ya maintenant à peu près un an si mes
souvenirs sont bons une question qui se
posait sur la date de ce référendum les
forces indépendantistes en nouvelle
calédonie n'était pas favorable à ce que
le référendum ait que le dernier
référendum qui est prévu par les accords
de matignon de 1988 n'arrive pas aussi
vite manifestement la roi que
aujourd'hui en raison de la situation
sanitaire entre autres peut-être aussi
du fait ils ne se sentent pas suivre
pour obtenir une majorité ils demandent
ce repas que le gouvernement et que
l'exécutif refuse ce qui laisse présager
en effet un état de tension et d une
situation de tension
vraisemblablement exacerbée dans les
semaines qui viennent et notamment après
le référendum alors guadeloupe nouvelle
calédonie corse ans la france fait face
à de nombreuses revendications plus
généralement comment jugez-vous ans la
façon dont le gouvernement français
répond
il n'a pas de stratégie aujourd'hui à ce
stade c'est une stratégie du cas par cas
avec un exécutif
qui quand même dans sa relation aux
territoires qu'il s'agit des territoires
métropolitains ou des territoires extra
métropolitain a toujours été depuis cinq
ans sous le mandat des manuels macron
plutôt assez centralisateur et c'est
d'ailleurs une des grandes surprises de
ce mandat c'est que emmanuel macron
c'était plutôt présenté lors de sa
campagne présidentielle de 2016 et en
tout début de mandat 2017 comme un
président girondin la pratique qui a été
la sienne du gois à la pratique de son
exécutif c'est une pratique
indéniablement recentralisatrice
recentralisatrice évidemment avec les
territoires métropolitains à certain
nombre d'associations d'élus qu'ils
s'agissent de l'association des maires
de france des présidents départementaux
des présidents des deux conseils
départementaux des présidents de
conseils régionaux se sont bien
évidemment émus de cette pratique
recentralisatrice mais évidemment
quitterait recentralisatrice vidalies
également des départements et des
territoires d'outre-mer ainsi que de la
corse la situation en corse aujourd'hui
fait que manifestement la question de
l'ouverture politique se poserait
peut-être encore plus qu'ailleurs tout
simplement à cause du rapport de force
politique qui est très favorable aux
autonomistes qu'on me l'ont montré les
dernières élections territoriales
arnaud benedetti merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire mercer vous